people say that we're like weighing this  up the suffering of the the animal  versus like the the taste of milk or  something or the convenience of milk and  what it really is is like the life of an  animal on one side of the scale and then  you have the the taste pleasure and the  convenience whatever  minus what you can get from a vegan  alternative i get where you're coming  from there but what if the problem with  reducing your animal intake is actually  chronic health problems and then what  you have on one side is an increase in  chronic health problems  and then that suffering compared to the  life of an animal there's this issue  with chronic disease in north america  it's like killing people and reducing  the life expectancy of people and if  that has to do with diet and that has to  do with animal products and we're  pushing  a vegan agenda to minimize animal  suffering without looking at that part  we are in for a world of pain  in like 10 years